these are products I don't use a lot of
people have asked me about these and
these are quite personal to me so I'm
not saying everyone has to stop using
them number one conditioners without
silicones before I bleached my hair it
was super smooth and straight Asian hair
any conditioner would be fine and it was
actually kind of annoying because I
couldn't review hair products well
everything was just like the same but
now that I've bleached it this was
actually bleached all the way to White
before putting on purple it is a very
different story it needs silicone
silicones are amazing number two mascara
I have trichotillomania which is where I
pull my lashes out when I'm stressed
it's apparently a pretty common ADHD
thing and mascara just reminds me that
my lashes are there and it makes it
worse number three products that smell
bad if they're too strong or too floral
or too I hate this but chemically if
they're fragrance free I'm in my 30s I
am too old to use products I don't like
I'll use them long enough to do a decent
review because my scent preferences
aren't the same as everyone else's sent
preferences but once that's done I am
done